this is just the tip of Shogun well to
prick an experience expressly designed
for the guests who find worst wall to
time we face this park on Japan's hey
everybody its Charlie this is gonna be
my West world episode by video we
finally got to see Shogun world we got
to see Rinko Kikuchi and a couple really
notable Asian actors playing out a
really hilarious twist on West world
narratives so really cool episode it's
the midway point so I kind of expected
there to be some sort of big climactic
moment and obviously that happened with
Dolores and Teddy's storyline with him
paying off one of those arcs that
they've been teasing us with all season
long if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
west-world
episodes but let's do top 10 WTF Easter
eggs starting with number 10 the title
so I believe the title akane know my
translates to red dance akane was the
name of Rinko Kikuchi character who's
basically the shogun world version of
Maeve's character so the red dance was
the name of the dance that she performed
at the end of the episode but it's also
a metaphor about what's literally
happening in the park right now with the
rebellion like the red representing the
blood that is being shed in the
rebellion so the red dance that the
hosts are having with Delos number 9 we
see Teddy's body in the future so this
is happening two weeks into the future
because we have Gustaf skarsgård playing
the Delos character so this is them
cleaning up the lake trying to fish all
the bodies out of it they say they've
lost about 33 percent as if their memory
cores have been completely wiped we find
out later through Teddy's storyline what
that actually means
but obviously the whole point of this
scene was to confirm that it was Teddy
that we saw floating beneath the waves
remembering this is happening in the
future they say that the cradle has been
destroyed where all their backups are
stored so they can't use any of that
information to reset any of these hosts
or to find out what Dolores has been
doing but also they remind you about the
swapping of those memory cores that I
think is all foreshadowing for Bernards
storyline the idea that he's going to
have to swap his consciousness and we
saw some footage of that in the teaser
for next week's episode but we can talk
about that next week remember he has
that memory core that's made for a human
consciousness we're all like who's human
does that belong to
I think the teaser confirms that it's
going to be
Arnold is coming back via this core not
somebody else but number eight welcome
to Shogun world so we meet a couple of
the big actors that we later find are
actually just versions of Maeve's group
which was pretty hilarious but all of
Shogun world was really badass I loved
the way that they set it up to size more
is much more useful in this place
because none of the other hosts like
Maeve are familiar with it so he knows
about all the narratives
he knows the geography he knows where
they need to get to but in no way does
that redeem him because he's effectively
plagiarized himself so number seven they
recognize it's an exact copy because
they have the exact same bank heist
scene that happened last season where
Ector comes to town with armistice they
try to rob the brothel if they have that
funny back-and-forth it was kind of
played for laughs
when Mae was starting to awaken to
consciousness because we saw a couple
different versions of it happen across
the season but it is really funny to try
and see the similarities and once you
realize that this is meant to be a copy
you start guessing which Shogun World
characters are doubles of which West
world characters Musashi feels like he's
supposed to be at door but he also has
shades of teddy in him too because Teddy
used to be a really important military
figure under Wyatt until he rebelled so
he's a ronin samurai I would say he's
more like Ector because they're meant to
be doubles of this but he also feels
like he could have some teddy in him too
like I said Akane is played by Rinko
Kikuchi she's basically Maeve's
character and the person that she treats
like her daughter like Maeve has a
daughter that she cares about
Akane cares about the Geisha Sakura but
I think this is meant to be a one-to-one
copy of Westworld then she's actually
more like Clementine but she treats her
the way that Maeve treats her daughter
probably the funniest part of this
though was when Sizemore started
freaking out like oh my god you're not
supposed to be here with your doubles
anything could happen
feedback loops and then they panned the
camera over to armistice who's staring
at her double like they're in a mirror
or something so I couldn't really tell
which direction they were gonna take
those characters but I did love the line
even a snake could be a dragon if you
didn't catch it that's because the
version of armistice and Shogun world
has a Dragon Tattoo instead of a snake
number six Dolores rolls into town with
Teddy preparing to strip the train down
so they can get Abernathy back remember
back at the beginning of the episode two
weeks into the future
they said that they were still tracking
Abernathy down so that sort of
confirmation that Dolores finds a way to
get Abernathy back at some point in the
future but number five the Shogun
narrative starts to go off the rails and
you start to see some similarities as
Maeve starts to flashback to when the
ghost nation in the man in black would
come to kill her and her daughter
it's ninjas this time and Sizemore still
freaking out they're not supposed to be
ninjas in this storyline what's going on
you have the standoff with the Shogun's
men maid gets away you also find out
about Number Four Maeve's secret super
power so this is just a more powerful
version of her vocal commands where she
can control the other hoes but remember
that hasn't been working since the
uprising so what it seems like is
happening now is she's doing the same
thing in a more powerful way using their
Wi-Fi connectedness remember these are
machines that are networked together so
they can communicate without actually
speaking so it sounds like she's found
some way to hack into that ability and
she's using that to issue commands to
all them the Shogun's men call it
witchcraft I call it really good Wi-Fi
but one of the other things that I
forgot to mention is is you probably
noticed that when the hosts were
recognizing their doubles and Shogun
world Maeve would speak or finish lines
of dialogue that Rinko Kikuchi x'
character was speaking because it was
the exact same conversation like
Sizemore had copy and pasted everything
from West world to Shogun world hosts so
that they would speak the exact same
lines of dialogue they would follow the
same type of loops with just a couple
cultural tweaks for the Japanese Edo
period but number three Dolores talks
about calling the herd with Teddy
foreshadowing that body that we see in
the future so you're like okay they're
clearly building towards this otherwise
they wouldn't have shown us his body at
the beginning of the episode what is
gonna be the thing that sets her off
where she finally decides to end him but
she has this creepy conversation about
what they do with heard that had been
infected by flies oh you're such a nice
person my father killed all the infected
so you're like okay very clearly she is
gonna get rid of him but it was just a
matter of time they spend the night
together and then she begins to
reprogram him which is probably what
they were talking about when they said
that the host mind files had been white
as if they were virgin hosts that had
never been put into the park so it's
like Dolores completely wiped them back
to baseline one I think to turn them
into drones in her army because remember
this is still set in the past right now
when she's reprogramming Teddy so they
still have a lot of work to do but
because she's turned them into drones
when she's done with them it sounds like
she just throws them into that lake but
the cool thing here is that remember
Shogun world a one-to-one copy of the
narratives in the hosts in West world so
who is the Shogun a copy of in West's
world I think based on what we've seen
from Dolores the last couple of episodes
she's the Shogun going off the rails
mutilating those under her like she's
mutilating Teddy by reprogramming him
the other comparison that you could make
too is is the way that Maeve controls
other hosts by using that mind ability
that she has and also the way that
Dolores is going to be controlling the
hosts by reprogramming them Maeve's way
is a little more evolved to lorises way
is through brute force like physically
hacking into each of the hosts and
reprogramming their files number two the
actual red dance akane know my so the
metaphor becomes a literal thing like
she's wearing a red dress that looks
like it has blood stained on it the
Shogun kills Sakura so it's kind of like
they're dancing in blood but the
metaphor dance also turns into fight as
she kills the Shogun while she's dancing
so if you couldn't tell the dance itself
the moves she was performing were
actually the events that had been
happening on the show so far
her hand sweeps up past her face as if
she's taking a mask off and showing her
true self it's like the hosts coming to
consciousness revealing their true
selves she kills her master the Shogun
the same way that the hosts have been
killing their masters in Westworld this
whole time so it's like someone told you
to explain the plot of West world using
interpretive dance that's what this red
dance is supposed to be but the cool
thing about this is that I think the
tune that was playing while she was
dancing was actually a wu-tang cover
remember most of the music this season
have been covers of really famous songs
but number one of course was made going
super saiyan or ultra instinct whatever
Dragon Ball metaphor you want to use for
her Wi-Fi ability to control other hosts
and has the Shogun's men attack each
other
draws the katana just as more are
charging in some real big telepathic
push like she's fighting with the sword
but really she's gonna be fighting with
her mind be
she can control other hosts now I think
she'll just get better at it as we get
closer to the end of the season so early
prediction Barnard says that he's
responsible for killing them all
maybe he also has the same type of
ability that maid has inked an area of
effect control hosts and forced them to
do things and mass she says that she has
a new voice that she's waking up to
don't be surprised at Barnard when he
maybe becomes Arnold because of that
special memory core also has that same
power but let me know in the comments
what was your favorite moment from the
episode and what do you think is going
on with Maeve's new ability and do you
think that that special memory core from
last week now belongs to Arnold and
they're going to bring him back
using Barnard what will happen is is
because Deadpool just dropped there'll
be more videos for that posting soon
leave all your requests in the comments
below
but click here for all my other
Westworld videos and click here for all
my Deadpool Easter eggs thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]